the internet lost hitch last night over
some salacious new gossip generated by
BuzzFeed about president-elect Donald
Trump the explosive leak is unverified
we don't know if it's true now I just
say we were working last night when this
broke I didn't really get all the
details I'm really busy but I honestly
don't see what the big deal is
everybody loves the Golden Girls what is
the problem
it's especially what's the big deal oh
and if they're peeing on you even better
well then at a press conference this
morning Trump confirmed via catchphrase
that his sons will be running as
companies I hope at the end of eight
years I'll come back and I'll say oh you
did a good job otherwise if they do a
bad job I'll say you're fired
he also he also promised reporters his
inauguration would be very very elegant
instead of popular a-listers an artist
that millions of people would be
interested in seeing his planner said
he'll be surrounded with soft sensuality
a soft sensuality I don't know maybe
like a nice romantic dinner at home with
Mike Huckabee in a velvet robe
and sensual don't neglect the Huckabee's
comedians with all this craziness
surrounding our golden leader how
exactly is Trump's inauguration going to
be elegant Emily he's gonna swear in on
a solid-gold Bible that's encrusted in
Swarovski crystals but it'll be the size
of you know like a cereal box to get it
a diner so that is his little hand looks
real big yeah okay boys boys Matt
kirshen it'll smell like the finest
asparagus yes points
but grace thanks everybody
I'm so sorry must have been hard for you
to start talking from that thunders
around we've got a good four years ahead
of us
I think this large red button will
launch my fireworks display okay
[Applause]